this is a Mekong giant catfish the
world's largest freshwater fish species
those species in the wild is critically
endangered which means that it's
threatened with extinction
and in the wild you hardly ever have a
chance to see it some of the
distinguishing features of the Mekong
giant catfish course it has a huge head
much larger than its closest relative
the river catfish the eye is almost on
the lower part of its head has a very
large mouth with no teeth so you can put
your fingers right in there and also the
Mekong giant catfish even though it is a
catfish adult fish have no barbels no
whiskers and so that's something a
little bit different than we're used to
with North American catfish the adult
Mekong giant catfish can grow to six
hundred and fifty pounds and almost ten
feet in length
this specimen here is probably only
about four feet long weighs
approximately 50 pounds so this is not
an adult giant catfish an adult giant
catfish would be about ten times this
size